this is quite a moment Saturday night
Tom will hit the carpet at the Beverly
Hilton honored for his work behind the
scenes with the coveted David O Selznick
Achievement award at the producers Guild
Awards from Mission Impossible to top
gun Maverick Toms produced 19 films and
made more than 11 billion at the box
office I felt I could be a good producer
I welcomed the
challenge this is very special
Tom's Mi Fallout co-star Angela Bassett
is on presenting Duty there the same
night she'll hit up the NAACP image
Awards She's up for Entertainer of the
Year Queen Latifah will host the
festivities which will Air live on BET
and CBS keep your eye out for presenters
including Zendaya and Kerry Washington
Brianna and Beyonce already took home
early Awards while power couple
Gabrielle Union and Dwyane Wade will
pick up the prestigious presidents award
for their work in public service it's
humbling and it's inspiring because as
much as we are doing there's so much
more the Duke and Duchess of Sussex you
might remember Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle nabbed the same award last year
we share a commitment to a life of
service and I couldn't be prouder that
we're doing this work together and on
Sunday Hollywood royalty will honor
their own at the 29th annual sag award
the statuettes are poured and dry we
caught up with Jenny and George's
Antonia Gentry who will serve as kosag
ambassador with the White Lotus star
Haley Lou Richardson it's an incredible
honor I'm very nervous though to be
surrounded by so many of my peers that I
look up to oh by the way I have
a Disney
did you not notice nominee Christina
Applegate noted this will likely be her
last award show as an actor amid her Ms
diagnosis she's up for outstanding
performance by a female in a comedy and
Andrew Garfield will present a special
honor of the night the Lifetime
Achievement Award to his The Amazing
Spider-Man co-star Sally Field I don't
know what I'm gonna say or how I'm gonna
say it but it means a lot and when it
comes to the evening's menu you are
making 800 dishes yes and we must serve
them all at once they must be hot they
must be delicious for the first time in
Sag history the ceremony will stream on
Netflix's YouTube channel the show will
Air directly on Netflix starting next
year we don't have to bleep people if
they decide to cuss a little bit so we
can get away with a lot more so you need
to watch because you know like usual
it'll get a little uh it'll give even
maybe a little what five percent Wilder
station 19's Jason George is on the SAG
Awards committee and his crossover
episode with Gray's Anatomy last night
was historic to be a part of Ellen's
farewell episode it's a genuine chapter
changing and that's that's not something
that happens every day Meredith gray
still a lot of loyal viewers were pretty
underwhelmed by Ellen pompeo's brief
farewell as a series regular one fan
wrote 408 episodes 19 Seasons 18 years
as the main character and this was the
goodbye Meredith gray got such a
disappointment but Ellen's not really
done you will still hear Meredith's
voice in every episode in the voiceovers
uh and I know I believe she's going to
come back sometimes you won't know when
so you always gotta watch to find out if
she just makes a surprise appearance
foreign